In the next variation
that we consider,
the random variable
Theta is still discrete.
So it might, for
example, represent
a number of
alternative hypothesis.
But now our observation
is continuous.
Of course, we do have a
variation of the Bayes rule
that's applicable
to this situation.
The only difference from the
previous version of the Bayes
rule is that now the PMF
of X, the unconditional
and the conditional one,
is replaced by a PDF.
Otherwise, everything
remains the same.
A standard example
is the following.
Here we're sending a signal
that takes one of, let's say,
three alternative values.
And what we observe
is the signal
that was sent plus some noise.
And the typical
assumption here might
be that the noise has zero
mean and a certain variance,
and is independent from
the signal that was sent.
This is an example that we more
or less studied some time ago.
Actually, at that time,
we looked at an example
where Theta could only
take one out of two values,
but the calculations
and the methodology
remains essentially the same as
for the case of three values.
So in principle, we
do know at this point
how to apply the Bayes
rule in this situation
to come up with a
conditional PMF of theta.
And the key to that calculation
was that the term that we need,
the conditional PDF of X, can
be obtained from this equation
as follows.
If I tell you the
value of Theta,
then X is essentially the same
as W plus a certain constant.
Adding a constant just
shifts the PDF of W
by an amount equal
to that constant.
And, therefore, the
conditional PDF of X
is the shifted PDF of the
random variable W. Using
this particular fact, we can
then apply the Bayes rule,
carry out of the calculations,
and suppose that in the end
we came up with these results.
That is we obtain the
specific observation
x and based on that
observation, we
calculate the
conditional probabilities
of the different
choices of Theta.
At this point, we
may use the MAP rule
and come up with
an estimate which
is the value of Theta, which
is the more likely one.
And then we can continue
exactly as in the case
of discrete measurements,
of discrete observations,
and talk about conditional
probabilities of error
and so on.
Now, the fact that
X is continuous
really makes no difference,
once we arrive at this picture.
With the MAP rule we still
choose the most likely value
of theta, and this
is our estimates.
And we can calculate
the probability
of error, which
with the MAP rule
would be 0.4, exactly
the same argument
as for the case of
discrete observations
applies and shows that this
conditional probability
of error is smallest
under the MAP rule.
And then we can
continue similarly
and talk about the overall
probability of error, which
can be calculated using
the total probability
theorem in two ways.
One way is to take the
conditional probability
of error for any
given value of X
and then average those
conditional probabilities
of errors over all the
possible choices of X.
Because X is now
continuous, here
we're going to have an integral.
Alternatively, you can
condition on the possible values
of Theta, calculate conditional
probabilities of error
for any particular
choice of theta,
and then take a weighted
average of them.
In practice, this
calculation sometimes
turns out to be the simpler one.
Finally, we can
replicate the argument
that we had in
the discrete case.
Since the MAP rule makes this
term here as small as possible,
it is less than or equal
to the probability of error
that you would get under any
other estimate or estimator,
then it follows that
the integral will also
be as small as possible.
And therefore, the conclusion
is that the overall probability
of error is, again,
the smallest possible
when we use the MAP rule.
And so the MAP rule
remains the optimal way
of choosing between
alternative hypothesis,
whether X is discrete
or continuous.